Шановні колеги знаєте в 2016 році а-а
тодішній парламент тодішнє скликання
власне ухвалив закон про декларування і
звичайно вся логіка його була в
публічності тому що Ну навіщо робити
декларації якщо робити їх закритими це
щоб сам по собі цей зал закрив
декларації після нібито 24 лютого потім
відбулися взагалі дуже дивні і цікаві
речі в мене велике питання зараз слухаю
оцю феєрію бажання відкритості
декларації а що нам пару тижнів тому
завадило підтримати 171-у поправку
Анастасії радіоної колеги ось цим
складом парламенту а що нам взагалі
завадило її ще комітетом навіть схвалити
І винести вже схвалене ну скажемо
відверто навряд чи бажання відкритості
було аж таким серйозним поки суспільство
Вибачте не дало по жопі цьому складу і
парламенту ось цієї петицією і президент
наклав вето на закриті фактично
декларації тепер друге питання яке ми
постійно піднімаємо і будемо піднімати
далі якщо вже так всі заявляють про свою
відданість відкритості то давайте ти
далі І давайте нарешті декларувати всіх
тих людей які причетні до ухвалення
державних рішень всіх цих позаштатних
радників які говорять від імені держави
Україна псують наші стосунки з нашими
міжнародними партнерами Давайте будемо
послідовні і дотримуватися своїх гарних
слів про відкритість ми голосуємо за